join us now as we proudly celebrate the
100th episode of the Google cloud
platform podcast hello and welcome to
episode number 100 of the weekly Google+
on podcast hi I'm Francis Campo and I'm
here with my colleague Mark Medel hey
Mark how are you doing I am so why I
wonder we have yes we just finished an
amazing amazing interview with Vint Cerf
one of the fathers of the Internet and I
feel like there's no intro neccesary
there's no cool things of the week but I
mean the cool thing of the week is we
interviewed Vint Cerf so I feel like we
should just give all our audience this
present and just enjoy yeah it's a long
interview so we want to make sure you
have enough time to listen to it all so
yeah let's just jump straight into it
for you enjoy so it is with an
incredible honor that we are welcoming
today Vint Cerf one of the fathers of
the Internet as the Wikipedia says to
the Google cloud platform podcast to
celebrate episode 100 Vinh thank you so
much for joining us today I am just
delighted this is the kind of
conversation I live for so I'm looking
forward to the questions and the
repartee
yeah I'm incredibly excited because I've
been a huge fan for a very long time
obviously but also because I took a
selfie with you three years ago in a
cafe in Mountain View and since then
I've always wanted to have a longer
conversation so all of these pockets was
just doesn't excuse to get to meet you
again so thank you for joining us I
really am delighted and there's so much
to say about how Google has transformed
its world in the Google cloud platform
something that we can all be proud of
but also recognize huge amount of work
lying ahead not to make it more useful
for our own internal purposes and for
the users that we have all around the
world cool well before we get stuck into
all that stuff cuz oh my god I'm so
excited if anyone hasn't had the
pleasure of knowing reading or hearing
about Vint Cerf Vint do you want to give
us a little bit about you and your
background and what you do at Google
well sure I'd be happy to do that I've
been at Google since 2005 I joined as
vice president and chief internet
evangelist and I confess to you that I
did not ask for that title I asked I was
asked what title did I want and I said
Archduke Larry and Eric and Sergey ran
off and they came back and they said you
know the previous Archduke was Ferdinand
and he was assassinated in 1914 and it
started World War one maybe that's not a
good title to have why don't you be our
chief internet evangelist okay I can do
that considering I've been doing it for
about 35 years before I joined Google so
of course before that many roles to play
in the evolution of the Internet and I'd
like to think I still have a role to
play Eric Schmidt our executive chairman
pointed out to me that I wasn't allowed
to retire I said why not and he said
because you're only half done there's
still three and a half billion people
that convert to get up on the internet
and he's right about that there is so
much work to be done also that actually
ties up really well with one of our
first questions which is so what does
vane serve do day to day well
fortunately my life is not repetitive
every day is new and different
I have many means like today for example
I was at the inter-american Development
Bank for the morning meeting with people
who are interested in making major
investments in infrastructure they're
trying to understand how they can take
actions that will improve access to the
Internet in the developing world they're
trying to understand you know what
conditions need to be in place so that
an investment they might make will have
productive results and
in that case of course we're worried
about the entire ecosystem surrounding
the implementation and operation of the
internet and the creation of new
applications that will be useful to
people locally in local languages in
addition to facilitating visibility for
companies in the rest of the world which
is something we try to do for people who
are advertising their products and
services so I spend a lot of time both
here in Washington and on the road on
policy related matters that have to do
with the use and abuse of the Internet
okay that's another big theme which is
that once you put the general public up
on the Internet you get what you sort of
deserve which is the general public
including people that don't have your
best interests in mind and so a big
issue for us and others that offer
services on the net is how to deal with
people who inject bad information onto
the network who commit fraud who bully
people who you know distribute malware
there are a variety of things that we
are well aware of things to headlines
that are harmful in the network
environment and sort of our job is to do
everything we can that Google to limit
the kinds of damage that can be done
while at the same time enhancing and
enabling all kinds of very positive
applications on the network so our
search terms or search engine is very
much a tool that people use to find out
you know what's available on the network
what products and services are there not
just on the net but in the general
nearby areas or even around the world so
part of my job is to help people think
their way through what conditions they
need to create if they don't already
exist to both build and operate pieces
of the Internet and then construct
applications on top how to enable it to
be beneficial to the people who are
trying to use this far-flung global
system I'm in the research group it
turns out and report up to John Jay and
Andrea and so I also get exposed to a
lot of the
things that are going on on the research
side especially in artificial
intelligence machine learning quantum
computing and things like that which are
well beyond my personal capability but
I'm fascinated by on top of which Google
has been very generous with my time and
so I do outside activities that
contribute also to this so I sit on the
National Science Board overseeing the
National Science Foundation which is
doing a great deal of research in all
the various Sciences including computer
science I had been chairman of the
Americas registry for Internet numbers
until the beginning of this year which
oversees the allocation of Internet
address space to people in the Caribbean
and North America I was chairman of the
Internet Corporation for Assigned Names
and numbers from 2000 to 2007 again a
major component of the Internet
infrastructure managing the domain name
system and top-level IP address
allocation google has been very willing
to allow me to spend time in the
internet space in one way or another
whether it's directly associated with
Google or more generally with the
Internet infrastructure and so I'm very
grateful for that
fantastic so much stuff to unpack there
I think that you clearly do so much
amazing things
why don't we sort of go back a little
I'm very curious about sort of the
history of some of this stuff it's
actually kind of hilarious we were
talking about this earlier and franceska
is in Paris France I'm currently in
Melbourne Australia you're in Washington
the very network and infrastructure that
you fathered for lack of a better term
makes this whole thing possible but yeah
you you are known is like sort of one of
the fathers of the Internet so thank you
very much for that thank you for the
credit to the extent that some damage
has been done I refuse to accept the
responsibility thank you for the dancing
sorry no there you go
thank you for all the good parts but I'm
super curious I mean when you were
working in this you know back at the
origin State you know many people
consider the internet sort of for those
of us who have become used to it and who
have access to it become almost a human
right or requisite part of existence did
you ever see that in the pathway of this
distributed network you were building
well I certainly never anticipated the
notion that access to Internet might be
considered a human right and as you may
know I have published at least one an
op-ed that suggested that that was not a
good formulation I'd like to come back
to that but let's go back to the origins
of this system it was originally funded
by the American Defense Department my
partner in the design is Robert Kahn who
at the time was at the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency this is way
back in late 72 early 73 of the previous
century god that sounds like a long time
ago and it was actually so Bob had this
idea that open networking would be a
good thing that the packet switching
technology of the ARPANET project could
be replicated in multiple networks some
that are mobile radio some over
satellite some over dedicated wire line
and that these multiplicity packet
switch networks needed to be
interconnected in a way that created
commonality and the only way we could do
that was to develop a set of protocols
that would let these disparate switch
nets look like one gigantic network
although made up of many nets so the
Internet is a network of networks we
developed the protocols and the concepts
to do that in 1973 and published a paper
in 1974 developed the detailed specs for
the protocols in late 74 started
implementation in 1975 ran through a
series of iterations four of them are so
stabilized the design in 1978 started
implementing it on many different
operating systems turn the system on now
January 1st 1983 now you might say did
you have any idea that it was going to
be global in scope the answer is
absolutely because we imagine this would
be needed
by the American Defense Department for
command and control that means it has to
work no matter where the Defense
Department deployed which meant it had
to work everywhere in the world so we
were already thinking in global terms at
the time that this design was being done
we actually didn't quite get it right we
we thought that a 32-bit internet
numerical address space would be enough
at least to do an experiment so we
designed the system to have 4.3 billion
terminations and that I think might have
been more than there were people in the
world at the time we were doing this
work however we ran out around 2011
fortunately the engineers who do the
standards for the Internet in the
internet Engineering Task Force could
foresee that we were going to run out
and designed a new format for the
internet packets that had a 128-bit
address space now we're not talking
about domain names which are alpha merit
for example google.com we're talking
about an underlined numerical address
space sort of like phone numbers
although the analogy is sometimes
doesn't work but it's similar in nature
so a hundred and twenty eight bit
address space is also referred to as IP
version 6 Internet Protocol version 6
which gives you 3.4 times 10 to the 38th
addresses which is a big number has been
at the forefront of implementing ipv6
for the various applications that it
supports and will continue to support
both v4 and v6 address spaces until such
time as v4 seems to be no longer needed
so we are among the good guys who have
been pushing v6 implementations it's
probably got to about 30 percent
worldwide on average although there are
some networks that are 100% capable of
doing both of older version 32-bit
addresses and the 128 bit and there are
some networks that haven't done anything
yet at all so there's still work to be
done the Internet of Things which is you
know threatening to overwhelm us in
terms of numbers of devices on the net
could have as many as 50 billion devices
in the system by the early 2020s which
will definitely need the ipv6 expanded
address faith mobile phones also are
dependent on this the thing you called
LTE or long term evolution which is
sometimes called 4G also makes use of
ipv6 address space so you can see this
proliferation of devices is driving them
finally with regard to Internet of
Things is something our company cares a
great deal about there are both the
production of these devices at nest for
example and at Google and there's the
cloud component of this which is helping
to monitor the devices to provide
artificial intelligence applications
through those devices such as Google and
sistent by way of go along or by way of
the pixel or or the Chromebooks or other
kinds of equipment that Google makes so
we are now faced with proliferation of
devices and also a great deal of concern
for safety and security privacy and
reliability of this increasingly large
system of devices all interacting with
each other and so that's certainly going
to be a challenge not only for Google
but for all the other parties who are
beginning to participate in the Internet
of Things there's lots more to be said
there but let me stop there and just say
that there's lots that I've been finding
myself engaged in because of this huge
investment that we and others are making
in Internet enabled devices so to go
back a little bit to the more society
side of the internet I cares about were
you expecting this huge change in
society like literally the Internet has
changed the way we do things we
communicate we work we do everything was
it something you expected - yes and and
I can prove this in the following sense
in 1992 I became the founding president
of something called the Internet Society
why did we call it that because I
believe that a society would emerge out
of the internet and indeed it has that
society may not be one that we liked a
hundred percent and this is what happens
when you create new infrastructure or
people and find ways to use it and to
abused it
it's like cars and the roads that they
drive on people get drunk and they drive
the cars and run into each other run
into things and kill themselves or other
harm other people
the Internet has its downsides it has
lowered the barrier to access to
information it has lowered the barrier
for expression to practically zero and
I've always thought that was a good
thing that we want more ability for
people to both express themselves and to
share what they know and to find out
what other people are willing to share
but at the same time we also have to
recognize that there are people who get
on the net and do not have the rest of
the society's best interests at heart so
we worry about fraud we worry about
false information or misinformation or
so-called fake news and things like that
we worry about malware that people
create and propagate through the network
and cause harm to devices that are
attached to the network or essentially
grab control over those devices and turn
them into what they're called botnets
which are sort of robotic networks that
can then be used to generate denial of
service attacks or to generate spam or
to do other kinds of things that are
potentially harmful so this huge global
system which has literally I would say
millions of networks including the
little local one that you run at home
for instance and then the big gigantic
globe-spanning networks of the telcos
and the cable code this this system is
like every other infrastructure capable
of being abused and we're experiencing
the effects of the society which is
emerging out of this technology so now
we have to struggle with protecting
people against harmful it
appearances online and sometimes we can
build technical means of protecting them
detecting malware for example did you
know defending against denial of service
attacks filtering out spam which we do
very well in our Gmail service so we
have these technical means of protecting
people two-factor authentication to keep
accounts from being seized or hijacked
but you can't assure that you can
prevent all harmful acts from occurring
on the net through technical means and
so you also have to build in mechanisms
for saying if we detect or catch you
doing some of these bad things there
will be consequences and here now we get
into international agreements because
the network is global in scope and the
perpetrator of harm may be in one
jurisdiction and the victim in another
across international boundaries which
immediately says that we need to have
cooperative interactions among the
countries that are part of the internet
environment there are just so many
issues here that we have to cope with
not only as Google but also more broadly
as citizens in the online environment so
I'm actually spending a lot of money
time asking questions about policy for
example and how it can be implemented
and enforced where does the policy come
from can we use multi-stakeholder
processes to establish policy and then
use law enforcement and trade agreements
and other kinds of things to enforce
safety for the people who are online to
enforce their privacy to protect them
against various forms of abuse and I
might point out one more thing as long
as I'm rattling on here that that this
lowering the barrier for speech means
that you and I and others on the net the
three and a half billion or so that we
believe are online now
have an additional challenge before them
and that is to think critically about
what we're seeing and hearing in this
environment because it's easy to inject
malware or easy I should say inject
false information or mistaken
information in the system and we our
search engine finds both the good stuff
and sometimes they're not so good stuff
and so as users of the network we
suddenly inherit this responsibility for
thinking critically about what we're
actually seeing and hearing and
questioning where did it come from
what's the basis for my belief that this
is useful versus bad information I think
a lot of people are a little
uncomfortable that they suddenly
inherited this responsibility but indeed
if you want to use the network to best
effect you actually have to think
critically about that so I think this
segues into an interesting topic as well
when we're talking about the safety of
the Internet and burthen malware and it
also from a societal point of view how
do you think this affects the either net
neutrality or the idea of net neutrality
does it have an impact or how we should
be thinking about that so this is a very
good question the term net neutrality as
I'm sure your listeners know is used in
different ways in different parts of the
world so we have to be careful about the
use of the term and ask okay in what
context are we asking the question in
the United States for instance during
the early 1990s there were about 8,000
Internet service providers this was a
dial-up system and if you to reach a
particular internet server and/or
service you just dialed a particular
number that got you to a modem bank if
you didn't like the service it was easy
to switch she just dialed a different
number and so there was quite a bit of
user choice in terms of access to the
internet along comes broadband and
suddenly there are very few providers of
broadband service that telcos the cable
code and that's about it so although in
recent times we're starting to see
wireless services increasing in their
data rates so that they could be
considered broadband as well so during
this period roughly
very late 1990s early 2000s in the u.s.
if you were looking at broadband service
as a consumer you didn't have very much
choice if you were in the rural parts of
the country you had zero choice for
broadband no one was providing that
service if you were in the suburban
areas you might have a choice of either
a telco or a cable Co and in the urban
areas you might have a choice of choose
suppliers of broadband so not everyone
was uniformly able to get competitive
access to broadband service this is
still a problem today and the absence of
enough competition and choice for the
consumers there's always the risk that a
monopoly supplier will in fact interfere
with people's freedom to use the network
any way they want for example if you're
in the vertical business of providing
video services in addition to underline
Internet service it might be tempting to
interfere with a competitor's video
service going through the internet
channel and in fact there were some
indications of this kind of bad behavior
on the part of some of the broadband
carriers who would inhibit voice over IP
or would interfere with with streaming
video in order to induce customers use
their service or possibly to interfere
with intermediate carriers who were
trying to carry a traffic and who are
getting squeezed and therefore quality
of service suffered so we have what I
think are fewer choices as consumers and
as the choice goes down then the risk
factors go up and so now you need some
regulation in order to assure that the
consumer interests are protected so the
net neutrality rules mostly is I see it
in the US are intended to limit the
ability of a broadband internet service
access provider to interfere with what
you do with the network where you go on
the net what products and services you
exercise that's why it's been a big
issue here in the US the ability of the
Federal Communications Commission to
step in
defend the users choices it was limited
for a time because there was a choice
made by the FCC to treat the internet as
an unregulated information service and
subsequently there was an attempt to put
in principles for net neutrality or
defense against the practices that were
anti-competitive when they tried to when
the FCC tried to enforce those
principles it was told by the supreme
court that you didn't have a legal basis
for exercising that control because the
FCC had decided that the internet was an
unregulated service so they had no basis
for regulation this caused the FCC under
Tom wheeler to shift the internet
service into title two which is the
telecom title reinstating the FCC's
ability to regulate and now of course
under the new administration abjectly by
the current chairman is trying to undo
that particular decision and to put the
internet back into an unregulated state
which means that there would be no legal
basis for protecting users whose freedom
of choice may have been harmed by a non
neutral provider so at this stage in the
US there's some uncertainty about
protecting user interests in other parts
of the world there may be enough
competitions of the users and simply
choose a different carrier or a
different internet service provider in
order to get service and there and
thereby use competition as a balancing
effect here in the u.s. there isn't
enough competition and so regulation
seems to be the only alternative that is
really concerning and I was actually not
aware of the last part so thank you for
sharing that since you're already
mentioning access to the Internet on
other parts of the world and curious
about since you are able to predict a
little bit that the internet will be a
global thing and it changed the world do
you think that having the rest of the
world get access to the Internet will
change it again or will be more of a
progressive well it will certainly
change it for one thing people half the
people in the world don't have
that's yeah and we already know some of
the things that have happened positive
and negative for the people who are
already online the reason I think it
will change although maybe not in
predictable ways is that the people who
will get access next the next billion or
two probably will get access to a
wireless method rather than a wired
method they probably will have the smart
mobile phones which now are heavily
populated all around the world they will
have needs which are have evolved over
time and so those of us who have been
online for especially in the broadband
world let's say for the last 15 years or
so have experienced the internet largely
through laptops
and now of course the rest of the world
is going to experience the internet
through smartphones and possibly other
smart devices as the Internet of Things
continues to deploy so their experiences
and their needs for service may turn out
to be quite different from what we
experience 10 or 15 years ago the
consequence of that is that there is
opportunity everywhere and on top of
which solutions to issues arising in
this vastly increased demand may
actually come from the people who are
new to the Internet as opposed to people
who've been around for a while don't
forget that the intelligence is
uniformly distributed around the world
but a lot of the smart people may not be
able to exercise their intelligence to
good effect with regard to internet
because the opportunities may not be
there there may not be incentive for
investment for example they may not have
the moral equivalent of venture capital
and risk taking which is endemic in the
Silicon Valley less so in other parts of
the world so I you know I think that the
newer inductees into the internet family
will experience new needs and come up
with new requirements but also new
solutions which may and propagate back
into the rest of the internet so I mean
to give you an example in China I've
been told in the eastern part of China
that don't bother carrying
everything is paid for with the mobile
and even the beggar ease you know hold
up their little mobiles and say you know
take a picture of this little quad you
know simple and transfer money to me
which is I mean that has to be a very
weird feeling you know somebody who's
begging using a smartphone saying wait a
minute you have a smartphone and you're
begging why the hell is that not work
but I will say in India for example
where digital identities have been
issued to some 800 million people these
people have suddenly become visible to
the government whereas before they were
not and they become eligible for
benefits that they couldn't get before
Estonia only has a million and a half
people they are as heavily networked and
internet enabled as any country in the
world and there are an interesting place
to look because when 100 percent of the
population is online with with digital
identities and everything else there are
things you can do relying on the fact
that a hundred percent of the people
have access as opposed to a country like
the US where maybe 80 percent have
access and the other 20 percent don't
say you have to accommodate that
statistic so here we are with examples
places are deeply embedded in the
Internet system and in digital
applications it's like explorers going
out into a territory which nobody has
been in and reporting back to us what's
out there so we don't have to make the
same mistakes they do
speaking of explorers I'm thinking like
possibly way in the future or possibly
not depending on some of the events that
we've been seeing lately around
interplanetary and space travel when you
built the Internet as it was were you
thinking about possibly interplanetary
networks you know having space stations
that currently orbit the earth and
having them communicate backwards and
forwards was that something that you
built into the protocol and design of
the system or do you think it's gonna
change going forward actually I know
it's gonna change because we're already
there or operating an interplanetary
system and the tcp/ip protocol did not
work and we when I say we I'm speaking
of the Jet Propulsion Laboratory at NASA
plus now many
the other NASA laboratories I started
work on an interplanetary extension of
the internet in 1998 of JPL and we very
quickly realized that the TCP protocols
were designed in a low latency context
with relatively high reliability in
space you have the inverse of that you
have low reliability and you have
variable and often very long latencies
we're talking about hours to days
so you'll ping is not your friend here
in terms of network management and
interaction you don't really know how
long it's going to take for an
interplanetary packet to get to its
destination they may have to hop through
multiple sites you know from Earth to
Mars to Jupiter and wherever so we had
to develop a whole new suite of
protocols which we call the bundle
protocol which is an instance of what is
called delay and disruption tolerant
networking so in fact we have thought
our way through that we've now deployed
first a prototype system on Mars and now
we've deployed the most recent and fully
standardized protocols on the
international space station and we hope
those same standardized protocols will
be on board spacecraft which will be
going to Mars and elsewhere during the
2020s so in that particular case we have
to accept that the original design
simply was not capable of accommodating
the kinds of lossy long highly variable
delay that the space environment
presents us with and so that's why we've
designed a new system but it's it is
interoperable with the rest of the
internet it just it's just that the rest
of the internet isn't organized around
that so we get protocols so that is
amazing
sincerely I'm really impressed with that
I'm wondering now is there something
else on tcp/ip which I'm not clearly
there is are these protocols still based
on the end-to-end principle like could
you tell us a little bit what is the
end-to-end principle and and is that
something that you're forgetting now to
go interplanetary it was actually more
even more important yeah well end-to-end
basically said you put something into
the net
work and in theory it should pop out
looking exactly the same on the other
end and you rely on the fact that the
packets aren't being altered or modified
in between this is still very much a
principle that lots of us would like to
hang on to as part of the internet
characteristic the reason that's so
valuable is that if you're building
protocols that are in at the edges of
the network building up from the basic
internet protocol this end-to-end
principle helps a lot because you can
assume that what was put in by some
party in some distant part of the
network arrives intact at the other end
now there are ways of assuring that by
using cryptography for example digital
signatures and other things to assure
integrity of the end-to-end the concepts
there have been some let me say breaks
in this end-to-end notion for example is
the internet deployed commercially in
the late 80s and early 90s we saw
corporations building firewalls around
their their corporate assets in order to
try to protect against the tax coming
through the network to their targeted
corporate infrastructure and that is
actually introduced down in the guts of
the network something which potentially
interfered with the end-to-end principle
because in fact the packets were getting
examined they might be destroyed they
might be perhaps not altered necessarily
although there's a possibility of doing
what's called network address
translation which in fact does interfere
with the end-to-end principle because
what may be sent on one end is not how
it looks something that's received on
the other end so I've never been a big
fan of this whole network address
translation because it violates the
end-to-end principle I think that over
time we will ultimately discover that
firewall motions are inadequate to
protect against hazards on the network
and then ultimately every device on the
network has to be able to defend itself
when the original design was done we
assumed that anyone could talk to anyone
else because we didn't know who would
usefully be able to
do that but we also said you don't have
to talk to anybody if you don't want to
and so if you receive a packet from some
random source and you can't identify
them or you haven't gotten a handshake
that says yes I know who you are and yes
we have cryptographic shared variables
if you're not satisfied you throw the
packet away or send back a rejection
notice I expect devices to do that I
think that's a responsible design is to
inhibit the device from doing anything
which it doesn't think is safe which
means don't talk to people that you
can't identify so I think that we were
moving back towards the end to end
principle and with the philosophy that
you don't have to communicate with some
device that you don't recognize and in
fact you should enforce that and I think
that will actually improve some of the
safety and security on the network
fantastic I am just keeping a very close
eye on the time so we've been talking
about very serious stuff and I want to
make sure we throw in some more fun
things in here as well noticing about
how the planning that you put into place
when you first build this whole network
and the planning that you've had
subsequently since about looking to the
future I'm curious to know though what's
been the most surprising or possibly the
most whimsical thing that you've seen
happen on the internet that you were
like that was never like I never thought
that was gonna happen well let's see
certainly to be fair about this
I think the arrival of the World Wide
Web was quite a surprise I had seen
something similar to it that Douglas
Engelbart developed and demonstrated as
early as 1968 in fact if your listeners
would like to go online and Google the
mother of all demos you will see
something quite astonishing which is the
demonstration of a kind of world wide
web in a box in one machine that Azariah
international in Menlo Park California
much of the world wide web is picked up
in that particular demonstration he had
hyper linking for example of documents
produced in the online system he hate
built a mouse so that you could point to
things on the screen and click on them
to say pay attention to that
go to that document or perform an edit
to this document that the place where
I'm pointing so he had to invent the
mouse he invented portrait mode displays
which made things look more like a sheet
of paper than you know that sort of
green yellow on green displays that were
common with the day so that Jim
berners-lee of course comes along in
late 1991 at CERN in in Switzerland with
an expansive network based idea for a
similar thing I'm not sure whether even
knew about the online system from Anil
Bart at the time and of course this
evolves into Netscape Communications
product they would follow onto the
mosaic browser and it suddenly triggered
this avalanche of content being created
by people who were able to either write
their own HTML or add an application
that did that for them I was totally
blown away by the amount of content that
suddenly showed up on the net that
people just wanted to share they weren't
asking for any kind of compensation at
all they just wanted thought though
maybe people would find what I know
interesting to to them and so I'm seeing
this pile of stuff just flowing into the
net and they mid-1990s thinking and then
of course Google comes along with the
with its search engine
following Alta Vista and Archie and
several other things Yahoo and so on
which helped to try to make sense out of
this increasing pile of content I was
amazed that people would share so much
information without expectation of
compensation and I'm pretty sure they
were doing it for the satisfaction of
knowing that what they knew might be
useful to somebody else
neither I think there is this this
secret desire in all of us to believe
that we've done something that's useful
for someone else we've shared something
that's helpful to someone else and the
Internet is a perfect medium in which to
try to do that so that certainly
surprised me now as far as things that
you know funny things well of course
then when the first internet picture
frame showed up
I remember thinking what what do you
mean the internet-enabled picture frame
what does that mean and of course people
said well it downloads images from a
website and then cycles through them and
that means the grandparents can see what
their grandchildren are doing when they
get up in the morning they just look at
the picture frame and it's just updated
itself from the latest website and that
surprised me on the other hand I do
remember in the thinking it was probably
in the early 1990s there was a or maybe
late 80s there was a convention or an
exposition called Interop which did for
interoperability that was started by a
friend of mine Dan Lynch and during one
of the Interop shows somebody decided to
put a toaster up on the network so you
could send an SNMP control packet say
help help burn do you wanted you toast
and we were all saying oh isn't that
funny ha ha ha and then everybody will
have Internet enabled devices on them
well now here we are the Internet of
Things is rapidly flowing on us but I
remember at the time we were all
thinking that would be pretty funny I
used to make jokes about
oh yes someday every light bulb will
have its own IP address well guess what
you know Philips makes an internet
controlled light bulb as do others I
suppose and they all have their IP
addresses so you know don't make fun of
things that because who knows they may
come true so those are some of the
things I think I suppose the obligatory
observation they never expected as many
cat videos to show up in the net as have
Wow you know who spends their time
watching cats okay so you mentioned Tim
berners-lee
and the world wide web and as part of
the research for this episode I'm kind
of forced that asking this question I've
seen a picture of the two of you wearing
both t-shirts were you wearing a t-shirt
that says I did not invent the web and
he's wearing a t-shirt saying I did not
invent the internet which is by itself
an amazing t-shirt but I think the
important part here is that it is the
only the only picture ever I've ever
ever seen of you not wearing a suit
right well and I kind of paint that over
my coat the story about the three-piece
suits if you want to finish this
interview with that story
absolutely oh yeah I'm at Stanford
University I've been running the
internet research program from there as
an assistant professor and the Advanced
Research Projects Agency says why don't
you come to Washington and just run the
whole thing and run the packet satellite
program and the packet radio program and
the packet security program along with
internet so I agree and my wife who's
from Kansas but it was with me at
Stanford says you're going to Washington
or we're going to Washington three-piece
suits so she goes up and she finds three
three-piece suits from Saks Fifth Avenue
and Stanford Shopping Center including a
seersucker three-piece suit because she
knows that it's going to be hot and
humid during the summertime in
Washington so I show up around August or
so at ARPA and the next thing I know I
am a asked to go testify it some
committee at the Congress and I'm
wearing my three-piece seersucker suit
so I show up and I do my testimony and I
go back there a weeks go by and one day
the director of art but calls me into
his office and says and I want to talk
to you about your congressional
testimony and I'm thinking well you know
did I screw up am I about to lose my
government job he's at the end of the
world and so I sit down he says now I
have a letter from the chairman of the
committee in front of me he says thank
you very much for dr. Cerf testimony by
the way he's the best dressed guy from
America we've ever seen positive
feedback so I've been wearing
three-piece suits ever since that is
amazing that has no change yeah I think
we you are still probably the best
dressed person
well camera here so that you can see I'm
so happy every coding face right now for
those who are listening on the podcast
Vint is wearing a three-piece suit right
now well actually a three-piece suit in
any case is that the
inter-american Development Bank with a
whole lot of you know very senior people
and so I think it's a sign of respect to
show up well-dressed when you're
speaking to people who are more
important than you are I'm so sad right
now that I'm wearing just the touch
well Vince unfortunately we are running
out of time I would love to spend more
time chatting with you but I really
appreciate you taking the time out of
your day to chat with us and come with
us and celebrate 100th episode it's been
absolutely lovely and in a complete
delight speaking to you today well thank
you so much for that I am looking
forward to spending more time with the
Google cloud team and as you know we are
making some very serious investments not
only an increased scale but also new
diversity in the system so as time goes
on we are going to see not only our
conventional CPUs but the graphics
processing units the GPUs and now
increasingly the tensor floral
processing units we're doing multi level
neural networks and eventually assuming
we're successful we will have quantum
processing units that will allow people
to do things faster than they ever could
before for certain kinds of optimization
so the the system which started out
being a warehouse computing commodity
commonality there's now going to become
a much more diverse computing platform
that can specialize to solve particular
problems that our customers have so I'm
very excited about this new
heterogeneous computing environment that
Google brings to its customer base
through the Google cloud that is
definitely very exciting and if you want
to come back to the podcast and tell us
more about it we definitely definitely
done for that I'd be delighted to do
that any time
all right well thank you so much okay oh
my god we just interviewed Vint Cerf
this was my god we gotta admit that
we've been maybe just talking about how
happy we were for the last 20 minutes
yep so I want to say definitely like
this is episode 100
to all our listeners total people who
have downloaded our podcast to all the
people who have wandered up to us and
said hello thank you so much for
listening to us but you doing that means
that we were able to interview Vint yes
also thanks to ving surf I know this was
amazing like a huge opportunity that we
have never expected to have and it was
you know because long time ago of 2015
2015 yeah we got to get in a meeting and
you went like why don't we do a podcast
and I was like okay whatever
sure yeah and a year and a half later we
serve and we have a hundred episodes
actually it's two years it's been two
years - oh my god I'm old 52 weeks
weekly episodes like yeah it's been two
years we're not going to go over our
favorite moments of the whole podcast
because right now it was this episode
clearly without losing any respect for
all the amazing episodes we've done
before thanks so much
also for all of the guests that we had
over those 100 amazing yes I feel like
there's one that deserves that like an
extra mention cuz we've had him so often
Paula Nielsen so Paula Nielsen thank you
so much for recording I feel like it's
been like four episodes at least we have
a section we have a category of the
focus which is Paula Nielsen thanks to
him - no absolutely and we should also
make mention to decent chunk of people
who work behind the scenes who have also
made this possible
great guy manager Shane if you run
social Neil and marketing I'm probably
gonna be someone through our editors
exactly don't forget our editors our
editors are amazing they do a wonderful
wonderful job if I forgotten anyone
I'm deeply apologetic but you're all
incredible did I miss anyone I don't
think so and if you did now I feel
apologetic too because I don't know
anyone else definitely like you all
helped so much and we are so so so very
thankful I feel like to celebrate our
100th episode since we got this amazing
episode as a present to our audience I
feel like our audience should give us a
present back they need to get in contact
with us yes they should send that
selfies a 100 episode selfie or
something yes yes yes yes pictures of
puppies cheer are also very good yeah
how can they get in contact with the
podcast going you know you know this
we're gonna do that okay so you can
censor your selfies to via email at
hello at GSP podcast you can send us
your selfies via Twitter at GPB or cast
you can send us your selfies on Google
Plus at plus GCB podcast you cannot send
us selfies through our website because
we don't have a form but it's TCP
podcast calm and if I'm correctly you
can also send us selfies on slack hash
podcast on bit Dudley /g CP - slack oh
one more I read it read it read it
rather I forgot about it read it slash
are slash and GSP podcast awesome so
yeah send us your selfies
we've just curious to know what are your
happy faces while you were listening to
this episode yeah please do well
franceska I know you're exhausted it's a
late night where you are in Paris it's a
very early morning where I am in Woburn
Australia
I am currently retired and I have a
burger waiting for me yep but thank you
to you for joining me for a hundred
episodes
thank you Mark for joining for a hundred
episodes to be honest it is not as bad
as it sounds they was very fun it was
[Laughter]
thank you for listening and talk to you
next week for episode 101 yeah see you
all next week
[Music]
you